c'est la vaisselle j'y peux rien au
contraire dans les années 80 on vantait
la douceur des savon à vaisselle vaudois
37 en turquie la vaisselle palmolive
tous les publics d'eau d'où peut-être
mais les produits nettoyants pour la
cuisine sont ils vraiment inoffensif
on peut en douter à voir les indications
attention irritant appelé le centre anti
poison ou rincer les yeux pendant 15
minutes mais que contiennent donc ces
produits de nettoyage pour qu'ils
nécessitent de telles mises en garde si
certains fabricants affichent leur liste
d'ingrédients
il faut savoir qu'au canada ce n'est pas
obligatoire c'est d'ailleurs sur le site
américain de procter and gamble que nous
avons trouvé les ingrédients qui
composent le savon à vaisselle dans des
surprises ce savon qui aident à sauver
la fondent contient du méthyl isautier
zoli nomme un agent de conservation que
l'on trouve également dans de nombreux
autres produits on voit passer un
produit qui est fortement non recommandé
le métier dix autres sièges jolie nonne
qui est considéré maintenant comme un
produit qu'on devrait retirer parce que
lui il au véritablement une déclaration
à la fois d'allergènes et sensibilisant
ya aucun de ces produits qui est
foncièrement anodin le chimiste
marc-olivier s'inquiète de trouver cette
substance qui peut provoquer chez
certaines personnes des réactions
cutanées sévères
de sensibiliser vous avez pas une
allergie médias mais peu à peu à force
vous en servez vous allez finir par
développer une réaction qui peut devenir
plus important et où des réactions
croisées avec d'autres produits
allergènes par exemple qui va augmenter
la région du fait que ça c'est
probablement ce qui est le plus embêtant
dans l'immédiat si on manipule les
produits les plus puissants sans avoir
une protection des mains nous sommes
donc en présence de produits qui même
certifié écologo ne sont pas sans
conséquence sur l'humain et il y a
d'autres exemples
alors je vais vous dire tout de suite
que moi je vois ici dans tous ces
produits là il y en a un qui est
beaucoup plus épeurante raison les
savons avec celle pour les lave
vaisselle sont présentement des produits
les plus brutaux qu'on peut avoir
niveau des ingrédients ici il commence
en disant que l'ingrédient qui le plus
important en quantité n'est que d'un
actif un père carbona l épais carbonate
c'est comme des peroxydes c'est
exactement donc une matière occident
très très très puissante qui est
dangereux parce que on est tellement
parce qu'on veut même pas gratter avec
une brosse on veut même plus la vie n
avec une lingette à vaisselle on dit aux
gens souvent la vaisselle l'eau votre
frère
mais quand vous voulez aller sur quelque
chose qui est plus dur à aller chercher
ben vous allez rajouter des agents qui
vont attaquer la matière quand on
attaque la matière enfin pas seulement
le dissoudre
l'attaqué s'est commencé à réagir
chimiquement sur la matière
il y à du père carbonate dans tous les
échantillons de pastilles à la vaisselle
que nous avons analysés
pourtant sa marque et biodégradable oui
mais on vous dit aussi ne prenez pas les
capsules si vous avez les mains humides
ou mouillé que de manipuler les capsules
qu'avec les mains sèches ça devrait nous
alerter là que quelque chose
effectivement qui va être très agressif
déjà sur la peau dès qu'on manipule les
capsules et qu'en est il des autres
produits parce que c'est dangereux
est-ce que c'est dangereux seulement les
plus concentrées peuvent représenter un
danger est réel si on n'y va pas avec un
petit peu de protection qu'un site rendu
à l'étape d'être en diluer comme ça le
niveau de danger lors il est bon il faut
le relativiser le pire danger qu'on peut
avoir c'est peut-être si on est
maladroit on n'a pas prévu le coup
puis on prend une signifie par qui se
dégage d'un produit alors que ça nous
surprend le pauvre rené en recul pour
respirer une bouffée de quelque chose
puis là on va avoir une réaction
d'irritation des voies respiratoires
voilà quelques-uns d'entre eux peuvent
faire ça plusieurs produits font en
effet appel à de puissants agents
volatile alors au lieu d'utiliser par
exemple
l'ammoniaque qu'on reconnaît oui c'est
ça ça nettoie c'est bien mais par contre
on oublie que quand on nettoie dans un
endroit qui est fermé qu'est ce que nous
laissons dans la maison il ya juste un
peu à force d'absorber le peut alan
thème qu'est ce qui arrive et vous
finissez par absorber la quantité qui
n'est pas tolérable
alors ces papous fait peur aux au
consommateur c'est juste tout simplement
qu'ils prennent conscience que parfois
en utilisant c'est un produit il faut
qu'il tienne compte
la concentration d'un produit qui n'est
pas toléré
ce qu'on voudrait donc c'est des
produits très efficace mais des produits
qui en même temps n'ont pas d'impact sur
l'environnement
et entre les deux beiténou film nous on
voudrait qu'il ait pas trop d'impact sur
notre santé immédiats alors il faut
choisir des marques qui font preuve de
transparence en affichant leurs
ingrédients et repérer les nettoyants
qui utilisent des substances qui
pourraient causer des risques à notre
santé
le métier l'iso siège all-in-one
l'ammoniac et l'ammonium finalement le
percarbonate la nouvelle génération est
très conscients de l'environnement est
aussi consentement de sa santé et ils se
disent mais quelque part la technologie
est capable de respecter ces deux choses
et de nous satisfait au final il faut
peut-être se demander si nous avons
réellement besoin de tous ses produits
ou si de l'eau avec un peu de savon du
[ __ ] et de l'huile de bras ne ferait
pas le travail
[Musique]
notez que l'eau et le savon ne tue pas
les bactéries le vinaigre n'est pas
reconnue en plus par le mapaq comme un
désinfectant donc ce qu'il faut faire si
vous voulez vraiment tuer les bactéries
sur vos surfaces de travail il faut
utiliser un bactéricide voici une
recette simple c'est de l'eau de javel
donc 5000 litres d'eau de javel dans un
litre d'eau et là vous allez tuer les
bactéries pathogènes comme colis
salmonelle ou comme un virus